are you feeling allergy I know I know it
[Music]
hey guys today's a new day he's cooking
I decided to turn on the camera and show
you guys my dope ass sandwich now look
at this I made the sandwich with King's
Hawaiian sandwich bread there's turkey
in there cucumber pickles tomatoes and
spinach oh and uh provolone cheese and
so as I was eating this I'm like oh my
gosh I should totally document this
because this reminds me of my childhood
days because I used to just make some
loaded as sandwiches I have three toes
too and I used to play Doritos in the
sandwich when I wasn't here but this
sounds like I'll eat them separate it's
okay there's already too much stuff
going on in the sandwich but yeah we're
in the middle of lunch
Isaak is playing hello neighbor please
and playing this non-stop for like how
many days I think like four days five
days okay my bed like two days oh you
just played okay sorry I missed a
general and yeah well I don't know the
days are starting to blend because we've
just been at home today was the first
time that I went out for
run so we ended up going to Isaac I
doctor yeah okay sorry trashcan is
voice-activated and there's also a
sensor usually we use the sensor but
I've lots of sensors because every time
I walk past the trashcan where it's at
right now it keeps opening and it just
thinks up the place where we don't need
the trench open so I've lost the sensor
so now we have to use a voice-activated
feature that's only if that's what was
just happening right now anyway we went
to Isaac's eye doctor to get more
solution for his lenses he wears these
hard lenses at night instead of wearing
glasses during the day so you've been
doing that for about a year I feel like
right now we got and then on the way
back we picked up some cat food I went
to the big and now we're at home eating
lunch and then we're planning on riding
bikes once we finish eating that's what
the day has been about today today's
Wednesday by the way and
Wednesday's RDK news prep days but this
Wednesday is different because there's
just not a lot of stories that can
really talk about I'm taking these that
have nothing to do with coronavirus and
we have been avoiding talking about
those stories because they were d
monetizing a lot of videos on the
channel now I'm not sure where we stand
exactly but I guess the plan is for
tomorrow to just do a whole bunch of
off-the-record episodes where we don't
have the news article to talk about we
just talk about whatever we want that's
my signature I know we talk about that's
all that's happening right now when we
were out on the freeway three ways were
like practically empty not really there
was a few cars here and there but not
for your typical like rush hour time it
was not that many cars and there were
signs on the freeway that said social
distancing do your part and since we
passed it I was like oh man maybe on the
way back when you get a photo of it cuz
I'm like this this stuff that we're
going through it right now I'm like this
is one for the history books nothing has
ever happened like this worldwide where
the entire world is on on one page and
it's like alright guys you're shutting
down we're shutting down are you gonna
shut down all right let's not spread
this anymore it's just it's like it's a
global pandemic like I don't know this
is wild
especially with the Internet just like
everyone being informed constantly it's
been kind of nuts and then we also got a
text from Bart and he has friends in the
Special Forces they told him that we are
going to be placed on a one-week
mandatory Lots
or like quarantine or something
nationwide and so right now they're
letting Police Department's know that
what do you go it now there aren't
detectable something we call it
something about tactical we're saying
technical alert but the news that's
being released right now so maybe part
knows a little bit more than what the
news is
oh yeah because Bart said to his friend
oh true you're saying that it's not
gonna be announced until this weekend so
today is it Wednesday right so now until
the weekend they're gonna start telling
people
according to Bart's friends I don't know
but what I've been reading as of today
is that the California governor is
activating not activating but like
preparing the National Guard yeah have
to do humanitarian services such as
helping get groceries for Global's so
people and I mean you know go out as
much and they're gonna help you know
transition everyone into this like walk
download what the whole technical alert
thing though what that means according
to Bart is that instead of policing to
find regular bad guys like day to day
bad bad guys instead now the police
force is preparing for possible riots so
in case like people are gonna start
looting so they're gonna have armed
forces out there to protect stores from
looters and rioters and I'm like
is it it's this for real like is this
really this crazy this is wild
but it's this real and a real wise how
does the David kid that David adventists
kid go oh yeah I forgot someone's old
over funny remember it really does feel
like is this real life right now
every morning I keep waking up I keep I
keep waking up and thinking like whoa am
I really like is this really what's
going on right now in the world and then
that night I could not go to sleep I
couldn't go to sleep I was doing this
thing remember how I talked about the
closet if our walk-in closet how I want
to do a closet system for my Kia so
online they have been so grab where you
can put in the dimensions of your closet
and then like build your own system but
they have so I didn't go to sleep till
3:00 and like messing with that just
distracting myself I guess that's kind
of been the situation at home the good
thing is you guys are watching a lot
more of these videos because our views
are going up yay is man that those two
waves of the Apocalypse that happened
over the last few years it really hit us
hard where we don't have nearly as many
views as in the past which kind of makes
me sad because a lot of people really
enjoyed our videos
and then more recently now that
everyone's at home they're like oh my
gosh I haven't seen you guys in videos
and so long and then they were like yeah
like you guys don't pop on my in my
subscription box anywhere like I'm
getting notifications anymore so I'm
like oh you guys could have been
enjoying all along but I'm glad you guys
are back today look at that sandwich
mm-hmm you're trying to one-up me or
what no it's the same thing you're doing
so instead of me and my I made a pork
yeah this looks good would you say you
got inspired from the Macao pork chop
sandwich they make in Macau but it's
like throws are deep-fried for like
fried and it's like left like toppings
and stuff but the marinade is like my
spicy soy sauce garlic and stuff like
that I imitated that flavor profile but
I just I just am fried mine tonight has
his work I never use mayonnaise in my
sandwiches oh yeah just you just squeeze
it yeah
oh it's not coming out the way I wanted
to why okay close it and then you kind
of just do this and then it should be
good one squeeze with the that's good
with with the consistent pressure so
yeah ever since the lockdown or not
lockdown but this whole quarantine being
a social dancing yeah it has not been
diet obviously look at this yes good
time
all right so we're all done with eating
lunch now we are getting geared up yeah
to go out and enjoy this nice sunny
weather I think just errant their tires
how nice is pretty pretty good with that
nice yeah we popped out the air
compressor now oh it was it able to show
the psi oh you just did it by hand again
loosing it by touch oh good old
old-school way you forgot your helmet
buddy yes you safety first
I know you did your hair but you need
you need to protect that scalp and we
have this high ponytail kind of makes it
difficult let's go enjoy the day your
butt sore me too actually my butt sore
from yesterday too
[Music]
all right it's been a whole lot of hours
since we went bike riding but since then
I think I picked up to go to his daddy's
house because tomorrow we're filming JK
news which means he can't really be with
us cuz we talked about a lot of
inappropriate things at JK news so I
don't like it when Isaac goes to the
office when we're filming and also it's
not fair to him he's just so bored stuck
in the office and like with headphones
on cuz I'm like don't listen to what
we're saying so his death victim I'm
currently trying to look for articles
I was actually checking out our most
recent upload and seeing what you guys
are saying so I was trying to respond to
some comments and you guys are so sweet
by the way you guys are still loving and
supporting and I just want to say I
really appreciate that and I love you
guys too
KC is currently upstairs trying to work
a bit cuz I had the music playing I just
paused it right now so I could start
filming which by the way shut up -
Keriann - Ana they gave us a Apple home
pod as a housewarming gift isn't that
sweet we've been using it at home and
it's been really fun having just the
home pod or what is it the Apple home
pod yeah right that's what it's called
I think now I'm blinking but yeah we
moved to our Google home upstairs so
it's so funny so you know how earlier
Casey was trying to talk to the trash
can to open something so we've been like
getting mixed up with like all these
like voice-activated things cuz we're
like hey Siri hey Google open can and
we're just like mixing it all up it
opened right sure open yeah oh yeah by
the way ignore that but we've been
drinking some angry orchard we've just
been like trying to pack the time in
Casey's been taking some shots of proper
12 cuz Kerry and Diana brought this over
to and then okay this is super random
has nothing to do with anything
but I just realized I didn't update you
guys kind of curious if you guys have
picked up on this or not but I took off
my buttons so I don't you guys could
tell but I don't
have my Invisalign buttons anymore so
I'm really really happy about that it's
been a couple of weeks now I think maybe
two and a half weeks since I took them
off and yeah it's like I got my teeth
back but it's only the buttons for the
top the bottom
I still got so I still got these buttons
you don't know I'm getting
self-conscious cuz we were just eating
spinach and I'm like do I have a spinach
ID oh shoot I do see ignore that
there I got it okay that didn't happen
oh yeah so the the buttons of my teeth
they're still very at the bottom but in
the top there god oh my god I'm so
embarrassed guys don't judge me it's
finishing my teeth you know what that
reminds me of that reminds me of that
scene from Emperor's New Groove or yzma
head spinach and her teething heels like
how long has that been there let's seem
just like flash in my mind yeah let's go
see what Kasey is up to right now I am
editing an Instagram video post
combining all those different times you
visit of the house while it was being
built and it's kind of cool to watch it
oh really yeah I kind of just see it
like and it's like rinky-dink Burwood
phase and then and I'm like sitting here
I'm like I'm in that place right now as
I bet they know isn't that crazy
we're living in the house that we kept
watching being built I don't know it's
thought to like tell myself and be like
whoa we're living here that's crazy
name and a year ago art where we are
living in right now I just didn't exist
before yeah it was a patch of dirt back
in June yeah July yeah passenger dirt
yeah and then now we're in March that's
crazy
it's pretty bad it's kind of kind of
frustrating to of opinion in your house
like getting Internet and stuff like no
one knew that where we were like oh yeah
they're like your address doesn't
exactly they just didn't know where we
lived cuz we didn't even exist
live in a brand-new house I guess yeah
well you know what living in a brand-new
house okay so you know how I mentioned
downstairs that I was watching or like
responding to some comments that you
guys were leaving in the most recent
comment I mean the most recent video and
then some of you guys were like oh
that's kind of worrisome that seen any
of them put batteries in your smoke
detectors
and I'm like yeah man isn't that wild
so apparently it's a common thing with
new communities being built where people
come to the homes when everyone's gone
and no one's working and then they'll
try to like see what they can take from
the house so there was one smoke
detector that kept beeping in that first
vlog that you guys saw when we first had
the the first night here in the home
someone came in and just took that one
battery because the other smoke
detectors they were fine because maybe
they were too hard to get to I don't
know but someone took that battery
someone took our griddle in the India
stove
downstairs in the kitchen that was taken
so the Builder had to replace it and
because it's not our fault so we're like
hey uh can you give us the griddle back
so big did and they also put a battery
in the smoke detector what was the other
stuff that they took the Builder was
like put wax on your oh the only thing
it was a circuit breaker breaker yeah
yeah you were taking natural with that
part of all my circuit breaker to iron
out the breaker the breaker
I don't know the breaker is it the
holding of the circuit I don't know who
knows but they were taking the parts out
and so I think they actually had to put
a lock on it and we moved in we couldn't
even access our own circuit breaker
whose the locks when the builder was
still on so we had the contact under
remove that lock and they're like you
should put a lock on that ASAP really
yeah which by the way the guy that I was
telling you guys about that had like
that very fatherly energy that showed us
around the house for the inspection and
all that okay that guy he was the one
that was telling us that yeah for some
reason there's like looters that just
break into these brand-new homes and try
to take whatever they can and get a
circuit breaker thing is one of those
things but it's so strange that in
California our circuit breaker is
outside of our home where he's like
that's weird like why does California do
that yeah that day
where my dad was fixing the toilet of
the day and like hooking up rewiring the
electrical and stuff I had to keep on
going out outside to flip it on and off
the breaker and it was raining it was
miserable and they have to half the time
I was thinking in my need electric
heater now I might meet electrocuted
really yeah it's like soaking wet
outside I'm like we're dealing with
electrical stuff I don't know maybe I'm
just paranoid I don't not experience or
nothing that stuff but yeah yeah I was
not that process because of that reason
with the rain and all it would be kind
of nice
and with the looters it'd be kind of
nice if our circuit breaker was indoors
or at least inside the garage it's
outside of the garage I know but we have
a lock now and that's locked up feel
like there were other things that we
pointed out that we were like um that's
missing can we replace that thing
because there were like a few things
around the house that were like why is
that thing missing I don't know it was
random but I would don't blame the
Builder they have been very good about
replacing and repairing anything that
we've caught so we'd have a pretty good
home on her hands I'm really happy with
it it's a small small place but like I
said before it's our starter home it's
not like we're gonna be here for the
rest of our lives it's coffee and it's
quiet and it doesn't smell like old wood
which all the other old wood you know I
really you really enjoy the smell of a
new home which I've never experienced
before in my life so it's really nice
not having that old wood smell which
it's funny because Kerry Casey's brother
thinks that that old wood smell smells
like poop he's like what why does every
home you live in smell like poop and I'm
like that's just old wood Carrie you're
not used to it it's so funny Maya you
decided to join us
you seem happier - oh I know they've
been so much more attached and so I'm
wondering I'm like is it because we're
spending a lot more time at home that
they're not used to it they're just
really happy and they're giving us extra
attention or what is
the elec us being quarantine my stay
quarantine forever human yeah stay at
home finally you get to experience life
with us
you look cuter also with their collars
on we've never put collars on them like
we tried once when you first bought the
collars but was too much work to put up
back on and I kept taking it on hand we
felt like that we felt bad for the cats
to at one point like we did they don't
like they're comfortable with the
collars on because they can't like
scratching this stuff I think that was
in their teenage years so they were a
little more rambunctious and they're
gonna like but now they're older and you
put them on they don't really fit with
it much as much so hey guys I had to
pick up the camera today because I'm
like I am NOT gonna break my streak I
think this is six days in a row since
I've been blogging so it's already 9:30
p.m. on March 19 and Casey and I just
got home from JK Mia's so that's the
reason why I didn't pick up the entire
the the camera the entire day but it
might possibly be the last JK new shoot
in a month because while we were filming
is when we got the notification that's
now the entire state of California is
under like stay-at-home mandate so yeah
that's the current situation so I talked
about this during JK news when Casey and
I were looking through news articles to
talk about today we came across this one
article about this taco spot who we're
selling these emergency taco kits and
they throw in like some toilet paper and
also some eggs and so Casey and I were
like oh man those tacos we've always
heard that they're really really good so
I'm like oh that's buy this taco kit
thing and also support a small business
so we picked it up after JK news and
then we came home and then the reason
why I'm in the garage by the way is
because the Chan clan are back so Mama
and Papa Chan came back from their road
trip luckily they came back safe and
sound
I checked their temperature and I was
like cool you guys are still good they
are still coughing a lot and mama is
like she has a lot of like allergies
going on so I'm like okay just you know
just take care yourself they're supposed
to go home tomorrow Kerry and Diana
they've been doing their own thing so we
haven't seen them this whole time but
now they're here tonight that's why it's
kind of loud in there so I'm like oh let
me let me catch you guys help really
quick before I bring in the camera so
we're about to have dinner
we picked up Isaac from his dad's house
yeah we got the whole family here we are
still being good because it's nine
people and not ten so that seems to be
the rules it's no groups more than ten
people and then while we Casey and I
were at jakey news Papa Qian finished up
installing another outlet and this time
it's in Isaac's bathroom so now Isaac
has the capabilities of having his own
bidet in his in his bathroom and so Papa
Chen was saying that he's gonna mail it
to us whenever they get back home or
whenever but I'm like oh that's so sweet
thank you that's like their housewarming
gift to us is installing outlets and
giving us a bidet
so that's really sweet I'll show you
guys in a second his finished work but
you did a great job let's go inside it's
a full house there's a street yeah my
parents looked us up they come back from
their trip Nijo castle or something
Oh a bakery stop
I soccer for me worldwide oh so many
veggies today well thank you mama are
you feeling allergy I know I know it I
want that high weight one yeah you know
and then all those Tolan yeah I bet you
guys were in the nature a lot yes she
would catch this funny bear captured a
sweet moment here it's are you loving
the love so how's your trip it was great
yeah I feel like I forgot about the
coronavirus oh that's good guys you
don't see any people day you don't see
it oh that's perfect I was quarantined
in six hours
oh sorry guys photos and your stories
and it looks so tranquil you look really
nice like awesome
like just is good we found restaurant
they had very good Italian food I was
telling them about the work you did
while we were gone how are you feeling
better are you feeling any allergy
perfect healthy as a horse
yes perfect what did you guys been up to
oh my goodness cleaving being pointing
it at the air baby we went out to a part
for a walk sounds about it - I think
that this is like the most interesting
like part of the day like we're working
on our laptops and just like heating
hanging out
yeah they're playing what is this NBA 2k
yeah to p20 everything in real life is
canceled and the sports is cancelled
might as well enjoy it in video game
wait Kevin Durant got it
oh he's fine all the athletes are fine
because they're all healthy good yeah
how about you baby how's your day looks
pretty good you got picked up yesterday
and then we just took up now we're just
chillin yeah same thing is here nothing
much nothing different
it was raining a lot yeah I was running
all day it's crazy
did you hear a whole bunch of airplanes
and helicopters cuz it over our office
we kept hearing a lot of planes fly by
we didn't hear anything
maybe isn't our area it's weird I don't
know could you show them oh yeah I did
talk about it but I haven't showed him
yet oh I put it in the it's okay they
know what it's my paper it looks like we
got one roll but this is the toilet
paper we paid 150 bucks for a very
important piece of toilet paper
well the advertise for rolls but I'm
assuming they ran out which is fine we
don't need toilet paper but they only
gave us one roll
yeah they do give us 30 eggs or imagine
toilet paper eggs we got some onions
cilantro Santa Rosa where they add rose
frijoles yeah oh my gosh I know I think
you hate beans we got it okay I got
sangria
oh yeah I could see that chicken and
stay for your boy oh boy I remember you
like on that side that's a yummy it
smells delicious
what song is that I know to my viral
video I remember that though yeah I kept
singing it for a long time I don't know
this girl that goes like boy yeah boy
yeah boy
I don't know and to celebrate we are
gonna pop the champagne bottle that
Kevin's to sever the first day of
solving that national drink oh yeah I
shot that music video sounds familiar
[Music]
alright there's a second time such a
tasty oh so I should have some right you
should have said I should try it if you
go to restaurant 300 bottles so I might
not have another chance to come watch it
I'm gonna read something maybe you go to
some fancy fine-dining
Steakhouse then maybe 400 in the other
blog cuz I only said you gave us the
nesting and it's like the doorbell and
the thermostat but you also give us that
champagne and an apple cider for Isaac
with fury kill Neal oh that was harder
to think
I don't think I expressed the right
amount of gratitude then to Kevin for
getting the bottle I didn't realize how
special with Baldwin who wants champagne
[Music]
alright so we're gonna do a Cheers but
really quick look at this vintage 2008
set as old as Isaac let's go this bottle
is as old as you isn't that crazy
you're gonna cheers with us with your
aloe vera mmm yeah
- family love you guys that's good
that's what we call it the good stuff
good stuff
you like it I like it a lot we ran out
of champagne flutes so you had to use
the wangal Wow oh you want to wave us
for your elevator see ya huh thinking
out cuz we're fancy okay ready
[Music]